seven people now in custody in relation
to this incident police say a 22 year
old man was arrested in the early hours
of this morning just before three
o'clock in London where he remains in
custody and as you say four other people
have been arrested on suspicion of
assisting an offender they're being held
in London uh seven people as I say in
total now in custody in relation to this
incident police have also said that
they've recovered a knife as part of
their investigations as a postmortem
yesterday confirmed that Cody did indeed
die of stab wounds and DCI in Ingram
who's leading the investigation for West
Midlands police has appealed for more
witnesses he said in a statement that
people are continuing to come forward
with information but I still want to
hear from anyone who's not yet got in
touch with us if you have footage we've
not yet seen or you know what may have
happened in the lead up to boxing day's
awful events I'd urge you to do the
right thing and speak to us right now
we're determined he said to get answers
and justice for Cody's friends and
family and won't stop until that happens
and West Midlands police also say that
they have appealed or applied to
Birmingham city council to review the
license of the crane nightclub in
Birmingham where Cody was murdered on
boxing day and a hearing is due to take
place tomorrow